let me say a few words about the
dissemination of scientific ideas i
believe that
all scientific articles should be freely
accessible to the public
they currently are not in one analysis i
saw
more than 70 of published research
articles are behind a paywall
in case you don't know the funders of
the research whether that's government
or industry aren't the ones putting up
the paywall
the journals are the ones putting up the
paywall while using unpaid labor
from researchers for the peer review
process
where is all that money from the paywall
going
in this digital age the costs here
should be minimal
this cost can easily be covered through
donation
advertisement or public funding of
science the benefit versus the cost of
all papers being free to read is obvious
and the fact that they're not free goes
against everything science
should stand for which is the free
dissemination of ideas
that educate and inspire science cannot
be a gated institution
the more people can freely learn and
collaborate on ideas
the more problems we can solve in the
world together and the faster we can
drive old ideas out
and bring new better ideas in
science is beautiful and powerful and
its dissemination
in this digital age should be free
you